foreign
I know a lot of people out there are
enjoying the beginning of the year it's
such a great time of year to kind of
start fresh there's something really
great about New Year's resolutions I
know they're getting a lot of hate right
now on social media but I personally
love them I love this time to reflect
and think through you know what was good
last year what was bad last year and
what can I improve on this year so this
month I'm super excited my family and I
we are doing a no spend January I love
how fun you make this sound because most
people listening are waiting for
something actual exciting to be said and
you're like we're not gonna spend money
it's so excited
okay so what's the the heart behind this
well the heart behind it is really just
rebuilding our habits so I I've been
saying that I kind of feel like our
budget has been getting fluffy like my
body has from all the Christmas cookies
so many cookies
so we're in baby steps four through six
and it's so easy to kind of get
complacent in this state you know it's
easy to kind of go okay we are saving a
lot to pay off the house but you know
groceries are going up so I'm going to
take a little bit from this line item
you know from our savings and just up
the budget and it's like before you know
it you're looking at your budget going
how are we spending so much money like
it just kind of creeped up so this is
the time where we want to go okay wait
we want to go back to when we didn't
have money when we were really really
fiercely aggressive about things and we
want to just cut back we want to cut out
all non-essentials so that's really the
goal is to cut out all discretionary
spending anything that's extra so money
will still be spent you still have to
pay your bills we're not saying don't
pay your bills everyone you'll be fine
no you got to pay the essentials keep
your four walls together food utilities
shelter Transportation but beyond your
normal bills there's a lot of luxuries
in the budget oh and a lot of things you
can cut back on oh yeah especially
eating out y'all that last caller was
saying that she struggled with eating
out and I was like I feel you girl that
has been such a thing for us we have two
small children a one and a four-year-old
so we've kind of been in the thick of
things and it's just easy to be like hey
Uber Eats would you like to deliver
something and also Amazon it's starting
to become so easy to just click without
even thinking and that's been really
eye-opening for me so it's January 4th
we've been on day four of this Challenge
and it's really interesting because I'm
already catching these habits that are
kind of subconscious like oh I need this
I'll just add it to my Amazon cart and
so it's good to just be mindful about
your spending and to just really take
that month or you know even if it's not
a month a week I've had some people on
social media say that they're just gonna
do three days and it's like whatever it
is that challenges you to kind of
rethink how you're spending rethink your
habits and really get focused and locked
in for this year I love it and one thing
that I've seen that works really well
for any habit you're trying to create
including a no spend month is to have a
calendar you can print one out for free
for January do whatever you got to do
and you just write a big X through the
day where you accomplished it where we
went we didn't spend any money we didn't
have to that's a win and then you don't
want to break the chain that's what
happens as you start Crossing out the
days and on the flip side of that then
you still feel like you're winning even
if you have one day that's off so I had
somebody on social media last night say
you know that they struggled one day and
they felt really discouraged but I was
like create that calendar because then
you can see that you know you have 31
days in the month even if you screw up
one day keep going this challenge is
still worth it so I want to challenge
the listeners if anybody out there is
you know starting this year and you're
feeling like hey I really want to get
aggressive with my finances this year
maybe you're a baby step two and you've
had that I've had it moment and you're
like hey I need to figure out how to
press in and get rid of this debt or
maybe you're like us you're in baby
steps four through six and you want to
pay off that house and you're you know
you're feeling the Press of inflation
you're feeling your budget get a little
bit squishy a little bit fluffy and
you're like hey I want to get serious
about this now is the time to do it join
join me join us I'll keep you posted on
my progress yeah what are your
parameters for this Christina can you
give us a little Insider details well no
eating out no fun money and we are going
for a 100 a week grocery budget wow what
is this 1950 Christina how are you
affording this people are going how do
you spend 100 bucks in feet and you got
a big family yeah so I have a meal plan
planned out I have all seven days kind
of mapped out I've mapped out how much
each meal will cost I'm actually about
to share that tonight a social post I
can't wait because I got reamed for my
social media posts saying that it's
cheaper to eat at at home than eating
out and the average cost was about four
bucks a meal at home 13 bucks eating out
and people are freaking out in the
comments going what did he film did he
film this in the 1990s you can't do that
in today's America so I can't wait to
see how much your meals are costing you
yeah you got a family of four I was
talking about per serving not
necessarily four bucks to feed a family
of five in one meal right well and part
of the challenge too is using up your
pantry items so we're gonna be going we
don't have a huge Pantry but we do want
to use up those items that sometimes go
bad so that's part of it and then just
being really strategic to figure out
what meals can we make with what we have
so so far this week I've spent 45
dollars at the grocery store wow where
are you shopping what grocery store
Kroger for us okay but I'm that nerd
that's going around like with my
calculator like writing everything out
and measuring everything out so that it
like actually fits within it but again
that's a good discipline because I think
we've gotten a bad habit of just kind of
you know getting what we need and and
kind of being a little bit lazy about it
so it's forcing and challenging me to go
back and go no I really need to go to
the store with a meal plan with a list
and stick to my list so I can stay
within those parameters that's big and
when you've got a spouse and they agree
to this it's easy because you have an
accountability partner who is happy to
call you out at every corner but if
you're single you gotta find a friend
who wants to be on this journey too and
they're out there friends I mean you can
find them you can find find them on
social media they're all over our page
join the Ramsay baby steps community on
our on Facebook oh my goodness there's
hundreds of thousands of people in there
who are ready to cheer you on heck yeah
and you can come to my page I am
Christina Ellis on Instagram we've got a
whole community of people who are doing
the challenge together and it's been
really fun even for me just to see
people chiming in I asked how everybody
was doing last night and you know just
to feel those raw emotions with other
people some people are like yeah Rob I'm
winning and other people are like this
hurts and it's hard but I love it and
that's kind of where that excitement
comes from is that I'm not doing it
alone and I feel that enthusiasm from
other people so it's a challenge I
already had to pack my lunch today
George oh my goodness I know that's
incredible I know what'd you pack
um I kind of just did a mishmash of
leftovers this would make all the people
who like their food separated kind of
grossed out but it was like all of our
leftovers there were people I found out
who are anti-leftovers they just will
not eat leftovers whoa like what kind of
privileged existence do you have where
you can just say no and throw away the
rest of the food if I did that in my
household Mama camel would not be having
it I'll tell you that much we ate
leftovers for days and it was great oh
leftovers are my favorite so me and my
wife did this Christina yeah we are
celebrating almost a one year
anniversary of our debt-free scream we
did on that stage uh just about a year
ago I remember that that was such a
great moment and she had the idea of
doing the no spend month and I text her
because I was like I don't remember what
we even did the specifics of it so she
said she shopped our closet so instead
of shopping for clothes oh yeah I forgot
I bought that that shirt still has the
tags on it maybe you should try wearing
that so get creative with clothes with
clothing she would even borrow clothes
from Friends uh she made sure she had
all the makeup and beauty products she
needed we would watch movies at home
instead of going out to the the movies
eat at home eat we could get a nice
little steak dinner at home instead of
spending you know 10x that eating out
that's so great and another really key
thing before you start is to analyze
your spending before you jump into this
so go back through the last month's
budget and you know see what did you
spend that was non-essential so add up
those line items add up those
transactions and then figure out your
total and that's what you can save
during this month and that's pretty
exciting because then you can set a goal
you know perhaps that's going to be
enough that you could knock out you know
your smallest payment and your debt
snowball or maybe that's going to be an
extra payment on your house so you know
use that as motivation to get excited
and kind of create a why you know this
month it's not going to be easy they're
going to be moments where you're going
to really want to spend money and having
that why clear in your mind where you're
like I'm doing this because this house
is going to get paid off soon or I'm
doing this because I am getting free
from debt you know have that Vision
clear in your mind and like you said
earlier it's like if you have a bad day
you know it's okay don't don't then give
it up and say oh you know not worth it
quitting now like use this as a
challenge the real goal is to change
your habits it's to change how you're
relating to money and really pay
attention I mean you mentioned the word
budget most of y'all probably are going
I haven't even really done a budget well
we'll make it really easy every dollar
is a free app that we created you can do
this in under 10 minutes you can track
your spending and you'll want to throw
up at first but stick with us start
doing the budget three months later you
build the Habit you've got your why and
all of a sudden you're accomplishing
your goals